à tours on connaît le musée des
beaux-arts le muséum d'histoire
naturelle mais est ce que vous
connaissez le musée de la typographie
non eh bien on va aller le découvrir
c'est un lieu qui regorge d'histoires de
l'imprimerie des premiers siècles avant
jésus-christ jusqu'à nos jours
celui qui en parle le mieux c'est muriel
méchant venez avec moi
[Musique]
du temps baer perfectionna l'imprimerie
n'a pas inventé l'imprimerie l'a inventé
la typographie qu'on appelle les
caractères c'est un gag avait bon
caractère
c'est la blague dans les 70 m² de son
musée muriel abrite des pépites d'un
ancien temps des machines vieille de
plusieurs siècles comme celle 13
typographie kg de 200 ans est en parfait
état de marche déroule au point de
normes sur la table en cage entre les
caractères on met la feuille au taquet
et les caractères vont imprimer la
feuille on peut faire mille feuilles ont
une heure en argent à la main avec la
main gauche on enlève la main droite là
mais priez bon jour là je vais doucement
[Musique]
est-ce que son temps je suis dit oh
graphie après la typographie on est
passé à l'offset fallait suivre
l'évolution
mais les entraîneurs il avait les deux
les deux procédés type typo et aux
recettes qui pauvres et faire les cartes
de visite ou menu des faire-part à 9,7
pour tous les dépliants en couleurs des
affiches
en parlant d'un primeur un ancien de la
profession passe par le musée ce matin
pour ceux qui ont pratiqué ces procédés
toute leur vie cet endroit est plein de
souvenirs et essentiels dans la
transmission de leur savoir et plein de
nostalgie
c'est pour ça que heureusement qu'on a
un homme comme le rial qui nous qui une
passion et qui nous récupère tout un tas
de le système et de de bois de deux
clichés qu'à une passion c'est un homme
à conserver car à 80 ans muriel est une
mémoire vivante de la typographie et de
bien d'autres techniques d'impression ça
c'est la xylographie la gravure sur moi
je vais vous expliquer ça c'est encore
plus vieux connu des chinois dès le 7ème
siècle
alors avant la typographie les livres
étaient imprimés mais avec des bois
gravés
après dix ans à tenir la boutique muriel
voudrait comme on dit en argot des
typographes chez dans le cast un des
apostrophes comprenez quitter le métier
et trouver quelqu'un pour reprendre ce
musée unique en france
[Musique]
on l'a vu avec muriel ce musée regorge
de plein de savoir faire qui ont
aujourd'hui disparu et si on peut encore
les avoir avec nous aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à l'association des amis de la
typographie dont vous faites partie
bertrand exactement la langue
pourquoi vous avez rejoint vous cette
association je rejoins cette association
il n'y a pas très longtemps enfin
content parce que c'est une association
qui fait vivre et qui soutient
l'ensemble de ce patrimoine et de ce
musée qui vient en soutien de muriel qui
a accumulé vous l'avez vu tout ce
patrimoine depuis de nombreuses années
et cette association fait en sorte de
faire perdurer tout ça avec peu de
moyens mais avec beaucoup de volonté
beaucoup d'idées en plus là on voit
qu'on a des pièces d'exception on l'a vu
à côté
là c'est pareil toutes ces machines
elles sont un peu unique en leur genre
celle-ci vous m'en parlait tout à
l'heure qu'est ce qu'elle a de spécial
alors ça c'est la machine en soi est
assez courante qui est très très rare
ici c'est ce sont des caractères en
braille et ça dans le monde aujourd'hui
il en reste très peu moi il n'en a pas
eu beaucoup de fonds dus à l'époque mais
aujourd'hui on a la chance d'avoir à
tour
une case complète de caractères en
braille qui fait partie du patrimoine du
musée et qu'il faut réussir à peine à
faire perdurer sur sur la ville de tours
c'est quand même l'objectif mais surtout
dans une ville voilà où les huées
vraiment d'imprimerie on sait qu'elle
des écrivains qui sont passés par là
sans tout autre chose en dehors peut
être chauvin on peut être chauvin il y
as et une ville de d'imprimeur de
d'écrivain et ce sans doute vu abraham
boss christophe plantin balzac qui était
à la base attendent est de faire fortune
tardivement dans l'ain dans l'écriture a
été un primeur fondeur de caractère qui
lui a pas trop réussi mais voilà on a on
a beaucoup de nassau cet esprit sur
tours et on a aujourd'hui ici dans ce
musée rassemblé de nombreuses pièces
vous avez vu les bois gravés de balzac
vous avez là des machines historique
il ya eu un potentiel à développer
encore plus qu'aujourd'hui
mais il y a beaucoup qui a déjà été fait
sur sur ces sujets là avec les écoliers
pour les petits et pour les grands faits
de ce musée l'est pour tout le monde du
moment qu'on veut découvrir cet univers
de la typographie et encore plein de
choses que vous n'avez pas vu et que
vous pouvez venir découvrir ici à tour